all right today's topic there's a video
that I feel like everybody really needs
to see and so we're gonna pop it in you
guys gonna listen okay I want to cut
right to it do it because you have one
of the most cutting lines no film you're
a goddamn cliche you validate everything
the white community thinks right and
that line is the reason I did the movie
seriously 156 panned you have two lines
in this movie that are extremely
important you have goddamn cliche you
validate where white people thinks and
it's not your first thought that makes
you a racist it's your second your third
and your fourth those two lines I feel
are the lines that everyone is stepping
around and no one wants to talk about
and that's what that's what frustrates
me where to put we're in a position now
in society in this country where no one
wants to listen yes nobody wants to
listen everybody wants to just talk when
you talk to someone and you have a
conversation with someone first and
foremost you have to understand that you
might be wrong it's the possibility and
listen to my buggies and people don't
let the air they don't listen I agree
oh that's woo your brother that hit my
soul oh my soul that went right in there
I was like oh yes at that point yeah
yeah step one to any good conversation
is listening and that doesn't just mean
not speaking when the other person is
talking but that means actively
digesting what the other person saying
in relation to the context of the
conversation
alright that's why we say there's a
difference between hearing and listening
alright so keep that the smartest person
in a conversation is the person who
listens so when you talk about black or
white when you talk about race when you
talk about sexism when you talk about
homophobia I think the most interesting
perspective is to sit back and just let
that person talk you know it's
frustrating to me that people take race
and they make it personal you know what
I mean
like we're we're at a we're at a loss in
this generation if you look at in the
80s Archie Bunker was a stark racist
start if you don't know hard your
baggage look em up
all in a family great show The
Jeffersons stark racist Fred Sanford
stark racist but you know what black
people and white people did they laughed
you watched 48 hours with Eddie Murphy
and Nick Nolte both of them hating each
other because he was black and because
it was white you know what they did they
laughed and right now we are in a
society where we can't have a
conversation because no one's willing to
listen people shouting people are just
shouting people walking down the street
hashtag and everything but no one's
listening
no one white people I truly believe
white people don't have an outlet to
express or question their views on race
why people have had a chance to express
themselves for the last 400 years no
it's time for them to take a seat
no no several seats and listen my [ __ ]
it is not for me to have to explain to a
white person why I'm offended I don't
have to explain to you what you're doing
wrong I shouldn't have to educate you
what man that don't work like that how
effective is that you got Google right
you believe in Google right then Google
that [ __ ] my only thing is this you're
gonna condemn someone as a racist you
should tell them why that's it if you
don't want to have that conversation
that's fine you don't have to about it
but don't say you're racist and then
they said why are you like whoa cuz oh
you don't know you should know no we
already this is what I know
I'm a certified scuba diver my first day
of class they told me this when you're
in shark-infested waters everything in
that water is considered a threat until
proven otherwise if it's a guppy it
could be a shark until you know it's a
guy and I think as black men we need to
realize we're in shark-infested waters
and if we don't sit our young men down
and we don't talk to them about
perception and we don't talk to them
about stereotypes we're doing them a
huge disservice because if the police
pull me over
prime example I got pulled over by the
police come over to my window flashes
light in my face hand on my pistol I
that two ways I can start yelling and
screaming and tell him he a racist and
he'll know meow you're doing this wrong
yeah there's a difference between what's
right and what gets you by sometimes you
just have to admit that you're trying to
live inside survive it doesn't mean it's
the right thing just it's not fair
do you want to live I understand getting
pulled over 12 times here can get
frustrating and you lose your temper oh
yeah I get it but I always tell people
you got to move smart they don't one
that have the power and that's a that's
a messed up thing you have an officer
that comes here after the most common I
filmed and whenever whenever I have an
encounter with them I film and I stay
calm now I used to be that dude but I
was like super violent and every time it
got me and more sure than anything even
when I was right you know but when I
film and have the proof that's different
thing you know when you don't have
anything to you know to show forth it's
a different thing at the end of the day
you trying to live they should not be
like that okay no they shouldn't but
they're like that women should be able
to walk naked in an alley and be fine
yes
I agree but that's not the reality is
I'm gonna make sure my daughter makes it
what happens when we have these
incidents that happen you know maybe
we've got different different evidence
we don't know how it escalated to what
happens when we don't ever get to the
court of land that's the problem that's
that's the problem
because now we're in a position where
you can't fight your battle because we
are relying on evidence we can't get
your truth as a black man your job is to
make sure your truth is heard that's it
so if the police want a while out if you
promise you if you sit back yes officer
no officer if I'm wrong arrest me
officer
are you talking back no sir officer why
are you being aggressive this is not
aggression officer if it escalates past
that there's nothing you could have done
anyway all cops aren't bad caps 99% of
cops are really good dudes at 40 we
don't understa Sizzix nobody can really
say what I do know is that good cops
report bad cops enough so for me they
got systemic problems at it yes I
wouldn't say that nine that brought if
your job is to protect the citizens and
your buddy is killing citizens or you're
not protecting since you're too pure Baz
bad as the person that does indeed
sometimes silence is guilt what are your
thoughts about the conversation thing I
feel the same exact same way is like the
conversation is gonna be able to better
things
even if you're right if you scream at
someone you're wrong you're wrong
nothing has been solved like that
nothing nothing
ever it's just aggressive it's just in
your face
it's just the person who's not gonna be
open and and glad to be like okay yeah
[ __ ] up not never ever if the
conversation is gonna be able to help
that but for that we have to be able to
have a conversation and people have to
be able to ask questions that's the
thing if they really want to understand
if not or just gonna run in circle
that's pretty much it that's pretty much
my thoughts on this video but we want to
hear your thoughts on this topic so
please leave your comments below where
do you agree or disagree with us and
what do you think about what and anthony
mackie said so leave your comments below
that's it
[Music]
what your dreamy black what's up bad
there we go wow what you're doing them
ghetto Pilates day you in it I I said
Jaheim you know take number bird working
on my get open that you don't listen a
job you just go oh come on Jackie that's
the hotel green I love Jackie yes you
know he's got good taste in music I was
kind of surprised by that one okay go
ahead
speaking of hood I don't know what it is
about makes girls and white girls
whenever they trying to imitate that
black essence they always do like some
x-ray black girls don't talk like that
no because because one because it is
personal decide people no it's very
personal but the reality is this if
you're ignorant about something and you
can't ask me a question so you're not
ignorant how do you get better so if you
come to me and you're yelling oh I hate
black people because of a B C and D then
you're ignorant you're a fool I can't
talk to you but if you come to me and
say look like my friends do it look you
know you're black dude I feel like I can
talk to you so I don't understand ABC
and D right and we have those
conversations you have my last wicked
whiskey and we have cuz I do the same
thing about white people agent before I
let you know people look I really don't
understand why I want to highlight a
difference see what his friend did
friend said I don't understand some
let's talk and there's a back and forth
there's a dialogue a conversation I was
super interested when I went to a church
with this white girl and a member there
was a picture of like a native person in
the church on like on the vegan you know
the one table I like the views it's a
native person on their knees kind of
looking up and then there was like
obviously the colonizer being like
giving the person bread mm-hmm I looked
at that picture and I'm like this is
hyper and appropriate considering our
history and she's like wives beautiful
art
and this person is not from here no it's
not from she doesn't understand so later
on that day and I was just like we don't
stalk about this so later on anisha's I
want to talk about what we saw earlier I
was like okay we can try and then she
started like tell me like what native
suffering is like here in Canada what
happened to them and I'll try to explain
to her that it's not the same as what
has happened in your country in other
countries it is a fairly unique
situation based off her own history she
kept like tryna impose on me the reality
of the situation and it made me realize
this person is just ignored on the
situation so I told her I just don't
want to have this conversation because
you're not aware of our history so it
makes no sense for me to debate with you
when you don't know the parameters of
this because when you don't know that
you don't know you don't know that you
don't know exactly so I don't want to
seem dismissive but I have to dismiss
the conversation because for me it was
going nowhere if you don't know what it
is that you talk about you probably
shouldn't be talking about you know what
I'm saying but sometimes people don't
know that they don't know that they
don't know that they don't know what
they're talking about it's funny to not
know it's well the promise is when
you're ignorant and you pretend that you
do know then I don't want to talk to you
because there's nothing for me to feed
you information with if you've already
filled that memory slot I can't feel it
for you with information so we're
wasting I have the promise to give you
an equivalent I guess it would be like a
physicist having to speak to someone who
works in coal mining about how how the
law of inertia works if the people don't
have a common understanding of physics
of basic physics there's not much of a
conversation that's gonna happen then
especially if the coal miners like I
know how physics works and he's never
studied it then it's a waste of time so
at that point then a conversation is a
misnomer doesn't mean that you can't
explain something complex to someone who
has no understanding of it in me just
they have to come ready to listen and
then have a conversation back and forth
does that make sense yeah absolutely
actually why don't we demonstrate the
difference between listening so why
don't you make I will listen to what
you're saying okay so what I'm saying is
that like you see if you look at a
camera the screen is crooked it's
clearly crooked it's not leveled so we'd
have to fix that because we're not
seeing herself level
I'm saying then that that that's not
actually better the whole thing because
it would give us a better view of what
we're actually viewing yeah you're not
wrong I think I have to probably
actually fix one of the legs the reason
why it's crooked is because the floor
slightly crooked but you know are you go
you're not wrong you can see it from
here to the foreskin yeah
and so the difference between hearing
now say something similar um
the light is too bright like it's really
bright we're like super pale on this
like it's it's burning everything and
stuff and yeah so I think we should
change that then can happen you always
come here in bathrobes why is it that
every time you come here to work you're
always in a bathrobe like this ain't
professional semi well what there's a
batter about to do with the lights yeah
serious question why are you always here
in a bathrobe uncomfortable because you
know they're gonna let you like all this
gay [ __ ] [ __ ] with his bathrobe looking
like he's about to like just flash into
you're like yo I'm put on some real
clothes I got real close right now it's
a difference they don't listen and the
worst thing is that when you're actually
talking you're like yeah I don't agree
with you you like okay bring your points
and because you defeat all their points
because there are points or week they're
gonna see that's the thing you have a
stance where you think you're always
right no maybe just your points are
garbage but I'm listening there's a
number of times that you came with some
Tufts and I was like nah man you run you
like you dissect that [ __ ] and I was
like okay come to think of it I didn't
think about it like that if you bring a
valid point I will I will be like okay
yeah I listen to you saying your point
cows have to listen to me what I'm
saying